hey guys it's Justine and today we're
checking out a thermal-imaging camera
you guys may be familiar with a brand
FLIR they are basically from as far as I
know one of the leading manufacturers of
these types of cameras they have all
kinds of crazy high-end ones but this is
one that works with your phone I have
some plans here this year to go and
start hunting Sasquatch again Squatch
watch so I figured I should probably get
some of the latest gear this is the FLIR
one Pro and what's cool about this is
obviously if you're not hunting
Sasquatch or things like that you can
use this around the house to determine
if there's leaks or really I'm not
really sure because that's really helped
and I'm gonna be eating it floor so you
can use it for practical things it's
like not hunting Bigfoot I can't find my
knife and not just one knife I can't
find any of it I probably have 55 and I
can't find a single one Oh see the heat
and this is it it's super small this
just goes right on your iPhone see if
there's anything else in the box a
little case some people don't like
custom cases for the things that I asked
so that we love them like look at this
it just fits perfectly in here USBC
charged it for an hour it wants me to
charge it for an hour so this is a
thermal imaging camera and what's crazy
about this is this can detect
temperatures up to seven hundred and
fifty-two degrees Fahrenheit that's
pretty incredible but you're not gonna
be seeing the way that you normally
would see through or regular camera lens
like you're seeing everything here
you're gonna be seeing heat maps and you
don't need any light to see so this will
work in the complete pitch-black let's
charge it up and test it out this is
exactly what we need to find sasquatch
we probably need a few other things too
don't worry that's why I've been on
Amazon all weekend let's go see we're
out here it's all set up now everything
is charged and right now I'm gonna take
my first photo here okay Tyler could you
move over a little bit oh my gosh you
got to see what you look like so it
looks like your temperature is about
well so it depends upon where we are so
about like 90-something Fahrenheit I
have the spot meter on right now which
you guys can see right here on the
screen so whatever I point something
kind of at the middle of it it will tell
me what that temperature is so right
here table is about 63 degrees
Fahrenheit and then we're gonna go up
there there's my bag and there is Tyler
I'm gonna take my first photo I favor
ready
so next door that looks like there's a
lot of action going on over there oh my
gosh it's like 131 132 what is happening
over there at the massage parlor and you
guys can see here in the settings
there's different overlays that you can
do so right now I have sort of a mix you
can see like the outlines of things but
you can also switch this to just a
thermal only and then you can click this
and this will give you basically what it
looks like out of a normal camera so you
can do a mix of both which looks pretty
cool because you can see that there's
all kinds of little outlines
and the thermal just gives you thermal
imaging and like I mentioned before this
is something that can work a complete
darkness because it's not really using a
camera or light it's using soot okay so
now I'm recording a video and there's
Tyler it's really funny because it looks
like if you're wearing sunglasses in
this video because of the temperature of
your glasses
they look like they're shades so there
you are
there's the massage parlor some hot
things are happening over there and it's
cool because I don't have the little
outlines on anymore so really all you're
seeing is the thermal imaging I'm so
fascinated by these types of cameras
okay Tyler let's see what I look like
here we go the justine is lava I'm also
I'm a little cold right now actually and
my hands are cold can you tell that my
hands are cold
I'm cold I'm chilled I am son I'm so
bright and cheery
so I guess now let's go find out who's
hot and who's not I know yeah yeah yeah
hold I'm gonna take your picture so
don't move this is so weird this is so
freaking weird I can't even handle it
okay it's weird it's weird I can't wait
to show you do you think we should go
get Starbucks I think we really probably
should go to Starbucks just so I can see
the temperature of the coffee to make
sure it's to my liking I just want to
make sure I want to check in on
Starbucks just to make sure that they're
doing everything correct
[Applause]
like at a grande nonfat chai grande
nonfat chai did you want that moderate
hot sweet site extra hot let's see how
the cold one oh my god this is
incredible
I'm having the best time of my life the
cold drink is 35 36 degrees Fahrenheit
hot drink 115 degrees
Wow hi how are you good how are you what
is the temperature that you guys grew
like the the milk - 150 170 degrees but
it depends on what the yeah like some
customers ask for cific orders so I got
mine extra hot what do you guys usually
do so which one you get the try key
what's it I did yes on the way oh yes oh
my gosh this is great I'm so excited
okay hot water okay this is awesome oh
my gosh
is that it right there is that somebody
else does the milk freeze okay I can see
so that one it says it's about 125 this
is so cool see this is your choice hot
water and extra hot fat oh my gosh it's
great so it's saying it's like 135 with
the foam yeah yeah it's really aerated
so you're gonna get a lot of contact
with air around it it's just so take off
the lid oh then you can swipe down and
see what it actually looks like like you
can even see the logo on there like how
cool so you can see like it's so neat
could you take a picture of me with my
drink with the camera cool okay look how
silly I look with my little smile in my
dream this is mixing the actual image
with the thermal imaging so you can see
like creepy excited Smosh the wonder
what'll happen when I drink it my mouth
will get warmer okay ready really
yeah cuz it actually I feel like I start
getting really warm it's really really
hot
what is it weird can you see it goes
down my throat really no way
shut up is a weird because is what is
happening oh my gosh this is so crazy
all right let's go outside to continue
our experiment we're gonna do a little
experiment so we were inside Starbucks
and I was drinking the hot drink well
now we're gonna drink the cold drink and
then drink the hot drink and I also have
very sensitive teeth so this is gonna
really suck
okay now drinking the hot have much
either this is terrible
this is torture
I'm just looking at your face and you
look terrified science is cool kavas
Lofty's incredible so the battery
illness definitely doesn't last very
long it was 100% we're now at 40% I
guess it's been on for about an hour so
it's not too bad but I think that we
should continue on and test out some
more things and then we're gonna head
back inside to investigate my home see
if there's any problems I don't even
know what I'd be looking for like what
am I looking for a problem like a leak I
hope I don't of a leak
wonder how hot and that he is he's
getting a haircut right now that's my
dog just you want to know ok just
picture it's nighttime and you're out I
don't know what you're doing you're
camping and you can't see anything so
here Tyler just hold this I'm going to
be an animal ooh night look at me I'm an
animal of the night
I'm an animal of the night
I'm Bigfoot I'm gonna definitely have to
test this out and pitch black and go out
and see if I can find some real animals
of the night cuz right now I'm just a
daytime raccoon that has rabies okay I'm
trying to pick up my dog
so Tyler do you want to wait out here
while I grab him and you can film yeah
see how warm his little doggie body is
oh my gosh you can see the pee more to
come of a child let's go home and
investigate my home we're back home now
and we're doing all kinds of things I'm
finding crime all over the place watch
this watch this I have spotted crime no
way like I can still see where you put
your handprint earlier I also put my
handprint somewhere down in there
actually right there I have an idea okay
could you hold this I'm going to lay
down on the floor and I'm gonna see if
my body imprint will stay here this is
true crime warm body no way oh my god
look at this okay let's see what else we
can find around here I wonder if there
happens to be any wild animals spotted
you're a hot boy it's saying Maddie is
174 degrees are you okay
oh my god this is terrifying you look
like a cute boy all infrared real hot
dog Maddie you learning can you picture
let me say kiss you are oh my gosh this
is where Maddie was laying this is so
funny it's 75 degrees there Maddie your
little his cross paws
okay let's go see what's outside Maddie
see if we can see any creatures in the
night so it's really dark out right now
your eyes can tell it's really hoping I
see a creature wait a minute
no not a creature disappointed OH
a creature of the night come on creature
of the night let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go creature so that's
something that I did I'm looking forward
to taking this thing out and finding
sasquatch thank you guys for watching I
will see you in my next video
perhaps with a sasquatch sighting do you
think I'll get like a medal or something
you know they've been looking for him so
long
[Music]